now when Jeff was born his mother's [ __ ]
during the delivery and when she looked
down she thought she had twins
stole a TV dog from BET
so you know what this was around the
time when bet wasn't playing my videos
and they was
[Applause]
the top to let them know I wasn't
playing
you just put it in the car took off put
it in the back seat like a human and
rolled off with him
playing the Huggy Bear part just seemed
like perfect and and you do a great job
in this role how did this happen he was
considering me for Huggy Bear with a
couple other people and I was telling
him I was like look man give me the spot
that's me I'm a Huggy Bear they can't do
it like I can do it and once I talked to
him I just put it out in the public and
let everybody know that was my part and
he couldn't do nothing but give it to
them
most [ __ ] like myself we go a little
crazy when we get famous
buy some dope cars [ __ ] some bad [ __ ]
but [ __ ] you bought a monkey
I mean that monkey was more embarrassed
than the one that started the age
epidemic
what do you think the devil is like
president
hey yo Katt Williams
when did they start selling pimp clothes
at Baby Gap
[Applause]
that's no dumbass questions
get get it all out get it on I don't
feel like [ __ ] right now [ __ ]
my life and feel amazing I took a loss
and I mean yeah
so who do you think is going to take the
victory don't give a [ __ ] stop asking
all these dumbass questions we lost like
eight you interview not be gone
Donald say he wants to run for uh
president and move on into the White
House why not
it wouldn't be the first time you push
the black family out of their home
have you uh have you hung out in in
Canada much oh yeah after that I
wouldn't shot a video out there
um went out there for a few basketball
games I love it out there they're
speaking English but you know they say
like a and things like that were you
were you picking up on that when you
were up there I didn't pick up no a but
I picked up the green
foreign
that [ __ ] was tight but you know who
else said that that was tight me 15
years before you did it stop biting my
you're five hours late here and shut the
[ __ ] up come on man no we just saw you
on Twitter about five hours late [ __ ]
I'm here and they could be happy I'm
here and ask some real questions yeah I
was just wondering what you did why you
were so late and I saw you were
twittering about stuff being stopped at
the border I was late because I went to
go get some chicken wings that's why I
was late Natasha legato legettao
that's how we said I've seen how you was
looking at me though right what I want
to know is have you ever sucked a black
dick before
[Applause]
hey I'm going off script right now I
just really want to know
now last time you were here you
proclaimed rather proudly that you had
uh kicked pot marijuana you had stopped
completely how's that going for you it
kicked me back
[Applause]
couple things about my girl Snooki over
there
oh that ain't snooky oh my bad I'm sorry
all white people who act black look
alike to me
I tried to listen to one of Ice-T songs
on the way up here but I didn't have no
cassette player in my car
[Applause]